[Music]
thanks for joining us today to hear
about automating large-scale migration
to Google cloud albedo strata we're very
excited to be here today for the first
time on stage as part of the Google
family following the acquisition of
Bella strata by Google literally last
month my name is Isabelle Joel I'm the
former CEO of illustrator and a
co-founder with me is Aditi Ghani former
CTO and co-founder and going forward
we're going to continue to lead the
Valastro era team and product so I'm
very excited about that so what you're
going to hear in this session today
about is how to effectively our Margaret
enterprise workloads to a Google cloud
at scale we're going to start with an
introduction of the product and discuss
some technical concepts behind it and
we'll dive in into some of the
automation and scaling features of the
product
we'll do a demo that demonstrates some
of these capabilities in live action
follow with customer case studies and
then summarize it an important note here
is that everything that we discussed
today is generally available filled
proven and ready to use at scale so
before I start I'll go to a show show of
hands how many many of you in the
audience are planning or have already
engaged in some kind of a cloud
migration form or premise to any public
cloud that's showing right and of those
how many are working on let's say it's
large-scale integration like hundreds of
orders or more production workloads oh
great so pretty wide audience and you're
in good company
in fact exploring recent reports about
enterprise cloud
option you see the picture is pretty
clear enterprises are moving away from
on-premises or even hosted data centers
so-called private cloud into use of
public cloud even you know the if you
look at for instance you know those two
columns here two years ago the
investment in on-premises versus public
cloud were similar and look what
happened in the last two years huge
difference building up between the two
looking at even if you look at another
interesting observation if you look at
hybrid cloud implementations which have
been widely popular and still are with
enterprise you still see some decline in
favor of more public cloud use so if we
if we dive in a little bit more into the
cloud initiatives we find another
interesting thing which is that the two
top most initiatives within cloud
initiatives are move more workloads
faster and deal with costs optimizing
the cost of workers that are already in
the cloud so why is that you know if you
look back to years ago there was been a
lot of focus on first
modernizing workloads optimizing for
cloud usage and then moving on what CIOs
are starting to realize the last years
is that this modernization projects take
very long time consume a lot of
resources in the meanwhile cloud
migration projects are being delayed and
that delay in fact means you need to
invest more in infrastructure this is
aging but you don't want to do it
because you want to move out so it's a
perfect storm and many sales okay stop
here I don't want to get rid of I want
to get rid of infrastructure management
moving infrastructure into service let's
just move it all and when they do that
they do it and say we let's modernize
during after in a programmatic manner
but let's start get moving out that's
this is why it's no surprise that if you
look according to Gartner a recent
report they quote the fastest growing
segment within the cloud business is by
far infrastructure as a service 36%
growth year over year growth over the
last year and forty billion dollar
business in 2018 so the bottom line is
enterprises are moving fast and at scale
but when you decide to move at scale
this introduces a whole set of new
challenges that you need to address and
to avoid a bottleneck in the migration
process itself so it's one thing to move
thousands of workloads it's all
different story when you need to deal
with thousands or workers they need to
be moved how to avoid this being the
next 2-3 years delay
what do you deal with multi-source when
you move a whole data center that
includes virtual machines but it also
includes some physical servers what do
you do with previous deployment you need
to another cloud when it was maybe the
only option available and now that there
are more options ah may be more
cost-effective how do you take at mass
large amount of Oracle's that are say at
AWS and move them into GCP how do you
deal with complex applications are in
the data center s AP multi tier complex
workers with large databases which have
very strict down time requirements and
then last but not least how do you
mitigate your risk in moving those
workloads many enterprise customers have
told us that this is actually a barrier
to adoption because if something doesn't
work I can't afford to have downtime and
that for four days without my
application running so these are the
main challenges and ven Estrada has been
designed for the ground up to address
the various very exact challenges this
is the enterprise grade field proven
solution that actually focuses on three
major use cases
number one data center migration
horizontally moving whole data centers
into public cloud number two the ability
to take in large-scale work with they're
running in a another cloud say for
instance AWS and move them into Google
Cloud and number three specific focus on
s ap you heard today in the keynote the
the partnership with sa P we're actually
taking the next level in terms of the
migration and offering working on sa P
migration both lift
shift as well as lift and modernize
meaning taking their existing db2 or
oracle or sequel relational databases
and moving into Hana in conjunction with
moving them to the cloud so let's talk
about the product
what does how does it really work so
there are two fundamental concepts
underlying level estrada
technology number one we actually offer
the ability to take stateful large
workloads running on-premises and
literally within minutes have it run it
in the cloud operate fully operational
irrespective of the side of the data
that is attached to that workload or low
latency is across the web we call this
streaming in analogy to video streaming
so you don't have to download the entire
video file to start watching it so in
the same idea you don't have to
replicate all the data to the cloud to
start computing it or consuming it so
the impact of that is that from a
downtime perspective you suffer few
minutes of downtime versus sometimes
hours or days but it also allows you to
start your validation and migration
acceleration much faster than other
solution the other fundamental important
concept is agentless design and what
does this mean this means that we don't
install any agent on a workload of the
actual machines that are being regulated
this is turns out to be hugely important
for enterprises because it means that
you don't have to know have intimate
knowledge of other application works how
to sync it up how to orchestrate
multi-tier applications and it turns out
to be huge money saver because it did
much less headcount and human manual
labor in doing it so those two agentless
streaming basically means much much
faster and much cheaper the other third
element is also being safer we'll talk
about it so how does it really work well
so the solution start with deploying a
virtual appliance which is right here in
the data source of the data center or
our
cloud and then there is an automatic
on-demand
and a scaler fresh and deployment of one
or more cloud extensions in the cloud
widgets of your choice could be multiple
regions etc then let's say that a user
said I'm sorry there's also one time
setup you need to set up the VPN you
need to set up the V PC and have after
one this set of the infrastructure
already start doing migration for
instance a user can pick using the
plugin that we have into the VMware
management console the vCenter can
actually pick one or more VMs or a whole
application and say I want to run in the
cloud
when this happens are right here back
hand appliance knows to take control
over the VM shut it down in a graceful
manner take control over is this and
essentially starts the boot process in
the cloud it's establishes a data
channel with a cloud extension which in
turn creates a whole kind of a virtual
disk in the cloud that corresponds to
the remote storage and then it starts a
boot process off of that virtual disk in
the cloud now normally this would be
problematic if it would be just simple
that it is this way but fortunately
we've actually implemented a very
extensive layer of wine optimization
that makes this work in as good
performance as our prime and sometimes
even faster it includes caching for
instance all the operating system images
are very similar we see 95 to 98 percent
similarity on different or similar
flavors and those can be completely
served locally we do for data that that
needs to be transferred we offer Network
deduplication our compression predictive
prefetch based on a number of heuristics
are read ahead and so on and so forth so
the vast majority of the operations
occur in the cloud we also commit all
the write operations locally in the
cloud using our storage subsystem that
is highly resilient highly available in
the cloud so the bottom line within
minutes you're up and running we also
have an auto adaptation layer that knows
to take the instances and convert them
automatically to be able to run in the
cloud driver injection
licensing enforcement's and so on and so
forth so the bottom line is you have an
instance running here and magically few
minutes later it's running fully
operational in the cloud now once we do
that in the background we kick actually
in parallel a data migration story to
test all the cold data and start
migrating it but important to note the
workers are already running operational
in the cloud while the data migrates you
don't have to wait for it to start
running while doing this the system
continues to operate and with data is
fully to really fully migrated then you
can hit the detach operation that
essentially allows you to cut the cord
and actually do the conversion to
completely cloud storage and then you're
all done important to know that while
you're at stage 2 and before you cut the
course so to speak you have the option
to rollback instantly within minutes
because we always keep all the changes
synced back into the data center which
is your again turns out to be very
important one of our customers Cardinal
Health reported about 4% of rollback
typically due to miss configurations of
the network or other elements elements
that prevent it from that workload to
operate in a proper manner in the cloud
so knowing that you have that allows you
to go at scale without having to worry
about what would happen if that workload
didn't work so very important so overall
again I showed you how do we take a work
lower than within literally minutes have
it operational on the cloud and now
we'll turn and see how does this work we
need to deal with hundreds of workloads
at the same time turn it over to ready
yes thanks for joining us for this
session so I'll talk about the features
that really make migration at scale work
and one of the things that we wanted to
ensure that when we go to the enterprise
we can fit into the way things are being
done in this data center today and
augment that with additional
capabilities for automation so that so
that you can weave it into your
practices whether it's work
flow management or orchestration so just
a show of hands how many of you are
using VMware on Prem that's great so you
know we saw a lot of customers making
investments over you know the last 10 15
years in their VMware environment and
that goes beyond just the compute it
goes into to operations management and
monitoring and health management and
what we wanted to do is is really take
that environment and augment it in a
natural way so that it will reduce the
learning curve of moving these workloads
to the cloud or using the clouds in
tandem with that environment in the
hybrid scenario so we've built the
management of our solution with tight
integration into the vSphere platform
into the vSphere vCenter web client
augmenting and extending the existing
objects that we're going to deal with
which is the virtual datacenter in the
virtual machine so you'll see in the
demo that we'll show in a moment you'll
see how that looks like in work now when
it comes to large scale of course we're
not expecting users to go and click on
each VM out of your 1,500 VM inventory
that you have in that cluster and this
is where we built a set of tools for
automation so we we have a published
REST API that you can go and use with
your favorite Orchestrator whether it's
we realize automation or whether it is
an SIBO or another solution of choice we
also offer a partial module for
scripting integration as well as a
built-in mechanism for orchestration of
the large large-scale migration and this
is what a feature we call the automation
runbook the automation run book really
gives you out-of-the-box experience of
migrating large sets of VMs and not just
individual servers but giving you the
ability to describe
all stacks full application stacks and
can be anywhere from tens and hundreds
of VMs as well as controlling the
information on how they're going to be
configured in the cloud what security
groups you're going to go into what
tagging strategy you want to apply you
can select what instance types are going
to use what disk types how they're going
to be called as well as the ordering
between the VMS when you're moving the
different tiers in that stack and we'll
see that all in the demo the automation
run book comes with a very simple UI to
use it also comes with the REST API so
you again can tie it into your
automation mechanisms and practices so
we'll dive into that in more detail also
in the context of the migration practice
and how to implement that now one of the
things that come up very often is that
when you're deploying in a VMware
environment you get built-in
oversubscription of your cluster
resources so it's very easy to go and
say I want a 12 CPU machine with 24
gigabyte of RAM and even if it doesn't
use it you're not paying for it any
extra but when it comes to the cloud you
get SLA around the system performance
and the types of machines that you get
but you're also paying for it so it's a
very important element is to properly
size your machines before you migrate
them now when we deploy in a VMware
environment we have the tight
integration that I talked about and part
of that tight integration is also the
ability to monitor your workloads
as they operate so while they're running
we will monitor them we will identify
their utilization of resources and that
will help us provide recommendation what
instance type to choose later on of
course after migration you get the
benefits of the automatic sizing
recommendations that are provided on an
ongoing basis once running in GCP and of
course for the sizing recommendation
we'll also take into consideration
specific GCP features features like
custom instance types is a very
important feature it allows you to
select exactly the size of machines that
you're going to need as well as the
consideration of sustained use discounts
into the cost decisions one feature that
comes very handy when you're migrating a
lot of machine is the ability to
validate validate your plan validate
your practice validate your
configuration and when it comes to
critical workloads sometimes you want to
do it you want to do the validations
before you actually touch your
application so we have the ability to
snapshot an entire set of machines that
are running in an application stack and
bring up a thin clone of that stack in
GCP in an isolated V PC or isolated
Network subnet so there's no conflict
with your own frame and allow you to
validate your procedure validate the
configuration validate performance and
you can do that in a click of a button
or an API call and you can do that
without waiting for any data to transfer
and this is the beauty of the streaming
technology that is he mentioned earlier
now when we're going to enterprise
environments in many cases they were
built to control there were mechanisms
built to control a lot of the incoming
traffic but when you're migrating
traffic is outgoing and this is where
people typically struggle in identifying
how much bandwidth they need to allocate
how do they govern the bandwidth that is
used for migration versus the other SLA
is that they need to provide to their
organization for because the users are
not moving to the cloud so in order to
eliminate the complexity associate
with deciding how much bandwidth do I
give this VM when it migrates over that
VN when it migrates and what do I do
when I have a data center that now I
want to distribute across multiple
regions because I have that capability
with a cloud and I want to bring the
workloads closer to the users so this is
where we've built a governed bandwidth
management mechanism that enables
enables you with a simple setting at the
site level decide how much you want to
allocate to migration and the system
will do its work automatically you don't
need to split it manually between the
different workloads and the number of
workers that are migrating worth
mentioning some additional
enterprise-grade capabilities
first of all securely encryption network
security and network policies the
solution has been built to be able to
work within your private address space
there is no need for you to open
internet access for it you can operate
it completely within your VPN and your
private address space and we support
features like private Google access so
that you don't need to expose more than
you were planning to okay we also
support features like working behind not
working behind HTTP proxies so anything
that you are familiar with from your
environment it's something that we can
work with and you don't need to go
through painful changes to your existing
infrastructure now
measurement monitoring is an important
piece how do you know that you're
maximizing your available resources can
you migrate more can you migrate faster
are you is the application getting the
performance it needs this is all
something that is requires the law
telemetry and a lot of you know from
VMware deployments on priam that
monitoring is is a is a difficult
environment to manage so we went on and
built
essentially a viral strata hosted
service that will perform the log
aggregation telemetry collection and
will give you the results processed and
analyzed into your vSphere environment
as readily available graphs without you
know they need to beef up the deployment
on Prem so before we dive into some into
the demo a little bit on migration
practices and in some insights that we
have learned together with our partners
and our customers in the process of
migrating thousands of machines first of
all it's very important to determine
ahead of time what is the inventory that
you want to move what do you want to
move first what do you want to move next
coordinate in advance with the
application owners coordinate in advance
with the infrastructure team with the
networking team identified the workloads
that you don't want to move so you don't
waste time on them identify workloads
that were originally problematic and
maybe remained on physical machines
because they couldn't be virtualized
before this allows you to plan ahead and
planning ahead is important because when
you want to migrate a lot of machines
when you want to achieve scale the best
practice we've seen working well is to
do that by establishing a pipeline make
sure that you always have machines
identified and ready to move create that
pipeline and you can migrate even
hundreds of machines per day
and for that discovery process we've
been working with various partners
partners like risk networks and cloud
Mies and others that are joining in and
and we continue to work with them to
optimize and they can also integrate
well with our automation run book and
REST API and if you are not integrated
and you want to be then this is all
public api's and we'll be happy to share
now
Automation is key and we'll show some of
it as part of the demo this is a this is
a case study these are actual
measurements from a customer project
this is a customer that has migrated
migrated several hundreds of machines
and you can see as we were working with
the customer to identify the best
practice for them to build the team to
build the migration practice itself we
converged with them on an agile approach
the HR approach allowed them to increase
their velocity eight to ten times which
means they at some point they were able
to migrate about 150 machines in one day
and what is that sprint approach or
agile approach looking light like if you
have a team or you structure a set of
teams that are dealing with different
aspects of your environment you can
create this pipeline where you spend one
week identifying the inventory for the
next sprint working with the application
owners to schedule the migration to
schedule the validations and then
prepare the automation runbook validated
the automation runbook is a self
documenting plan so you don't need to do
that twice and then going to the next
week and you execute the plan the
machines migrate and are live within
typically just a couple of hours so you
can have your application orders come in
on a predictable schedule perform the
validation and and in handover to the
users and after a set of trial period
you can decide to cut the cord and
complete the migration or if any issues
came up and there are unexpected
leverage our rollback feature to be able
to move the machines to operate back on
prime with full consistent state so this
is an example of a sprint that were
migrating about 70 plus machines in one
go and what you can see here in the
graph
is that the blue line and don't catch me
on the color is the number of machines
that were running and how long it takes
for them it took for them to actually
run and be live in the cloud and you can
see that within about two hours the
entire set of machines across all the
migration groups and tears were up and
running within the next day and a half
the data was migrated in the background
but that doesn't prevent the application
from running which means you can be live
in the cloud in just minutes regardless
of the size so we'll switch over to a
quick demo we didn't have much time we
had a lot to show so we're going to show
a time sped recorded demo we have a
showcase downstairs that you can go in
and play with that with these different
scenarios interactively so first we'll
start with the vCenter integration and
go through that quickly so this is the
well-known vSphere web client user
interface and you can see the
integration through extension of the
virtual machine object so you can select
a virtual machine right click on it and
you'll get the well-trodden menu you
have several options for the migration a
two notable ones or the running cloud
option which allows you to take any
workload run it in the cloud in minutes
without having to move the storage this
is good if you want to try things if you
want to test how your machine will work
on a machine with four terabytes of RAM
how will it work with on a machine with
128 CPUs how will it work with a GPU or
a TPU that you never had access to you
can do that without having to resort to
building your application from scratch
and regardless of how much data you have
it will be accessible using our
streaming mechanism the second notable
option is migrated you decide
that you want to move let's do that so
we'll click on migrate and you'll get a
very simple wizard built into the system
you'll select your target your target
VPC you'll select your target machine
type and this is where you can see the
different right sizing recommendations
coming in whether you want the machine
that best fits the current provision
size on VMware or whether you want one
that is based on the actual utilization
which in this case is very low
utilization then you'll select the
storage policy and we can talk about
that offline select the disk type and
that's it you're ready to go so let's
click finish and now we'll see the
integration into the vSphere interface
from a monitoring perspective there is a
portlet that shows up for that machine
so we're not creating a new object we're
not creating we're not losing the admin
context for that machine and as you can
see within the vSphere environment you
can see the status of the machine
running in the cloud and the status of
its migration so this machine had has
over terabyte worth of disks about three
disks and it is up and running in 11
minutes another thing you can see in
this is the integration the further
integration we did into vSphere which is
integration into events and issues and
alarms so it will all propagate into
your VIII realize operation management
11 minutes over one terabyte it took me
longer to upload the video so let's see
what happens if things don't work as
well maybe there's a quota issue maybe
the application owner is not ready to
come in and do the validation so you
need to roll back rolling back is as
easy as moving to the cloud so this
machine has been going on it
running live storage is migrating in the
background as you can see in the bar
here and we decided that we want to move
it back
so another right-click on that VM and
we'll select the run on premises and
that's it just a single click and what
you'll see is that the system will be
back on Prem in just a few minutes since
the system is running in the cloud we
constantly synchronize the change set
that was happening in the last few
minutes or up to certain change capacity
and will replicate it back on Prem to
the disk on Prem so you can move back at
any point in time and if you have backup
happening on Prem it will always back up
the latest version of that machine while
it's running in the cloud so this is the
integration into the web UI kind of
tasting that let's talk about the
runbook automation obviously when you
have 1500 machines and when you have
stacks of 30 machines or more you're not
going to do multi select or do that
manually so this is where our own book
automation features into play and we'll
start with a simple a simple multi tier
application this is the Sugar CRM setup
and you can see this application running
on Prem on the VMware side we'll even go
and create some new state add some data
just to demonstrate that you can migrate
immediately without having to deal with
complex synchronization and cutover
so lets migrate that application first
we'll create a run book to create the
run book you go into the well Shradha
web interface select your source vSphere
or AWS additional sources will come
later you'll select your source data
center or virtual data center where your
inventory resides and the target cloud
they we are going to get the wrong book
export exported in CSV format so
very easy to work with in spreadsheet
editor so let's take that inventory that
was exported a lot of information is
already included there
what's the configuration on Prem what's
the naming as well as default selections
for the target and then next thing we'll
do is filter out that inventory just the
set that we want to migrate in this run
and we will also create order this
allows you to take a multi-tier
application define the different
components in each tier identify the
order between them and also identify
service probes so when a certain tier is
coming up you can probe that the service
is available before you start up the
next set of VMs in that tier so let's
take that CSV file and save it next
thing we want to do is apply right
sizing to to that so we'll take the CSV
file that we filtered we'll input it
into the recommendation engine and we'll
get right sizing recommendations built
into the entire set of machines that are
in that spreadsheet we'll select the
relevant recommendations copy them over
to the target instance type that we want
to use and the run book is ready now as
you can see the run book is a self
documenting plan which means you don't
have to take all that information and
keep it in other inventories in other
repositories we'll take that run book
and you can apply additional information
there like you're tagging strategy
define your labels and they will be
applied when the machines are moving so
let's go and start the migration job
now the migration is done on a full set
of machines to verify the operation the
progress etc you go into the monitoring
page and this is where you will see the
state of each VM that is currently
migrating effectively you will see the
system changed or state as they go
through coming up live transferring the
storage and ready to detach when it's
ready to detach the migration
effectively is completed so let's look
at the application the application is
now online
okay so what we have in the showcase
downstairs is also a demo of additional
scenarios moving from AWS to GCP using
the automation runbook and again the
automation run book is fully available
both in the UI and in REST API so you
can tie to your own orchestration on all
your own automation procedures so there
were many times we have want to see how
all this great technology translate into
actual business benefits for the
customers through some case studies of
actual customers that we've deployed our
solution with and so we've done numerous
appointments thousands of yemm's - you
know from one premises public cloud for
example over one public sector company
in the UK that actually has been running
into issues with respect to having to
vacatur hosted data center within six
months they were way way behind
timelines and budget we're introduced
into that scenario and within pretty
much six weeks and about 10x faster
completely the migration in time and
there's as you can see different
segments interesting segments that we've
been working in healthcare is one
financial oil and energy and few others
and what comes across is really you know
three major benefits one significant
time savings
number two significant cost savings a
number three safe journey right and this
is all what you see in our solution
what's like specifically Cardinal health
which has been we've gone through an
interesting journey
they've gone you know come to the
conclusion that they need to again
decommission our data centers do and
move on all weighing of several data
centers to the cloud they started the
journey actually with a different loud
AWS actually and moved with lost Rara
quite a bit of workers again they had
constraints they have budget constraints
and basically decided after selecting or
basically testing a few a few solutions
to go with La Strada
and we were able to migrate about
thousand servers within six months by
the way not all of it is actual
migration as the de pointed out or
discovery there's planning and
assessment getting alignment from
application owners all these come into
play but a rough we are cadence of one
hundred service per week or five
thousand service per year is something
we were saying consistently happening
with a lot of our customers using our
solution and then midway through the
repop journey into one cloud they
decided on a made a business decision to
switch to go to another cloud this time
to Google Cloud and during that time
they also use La Strada to actually make
all that transition very effectively and
actually as we speak they're moving
hundreds of machines per week with us
and you can see savings of millions of
dollars due to the fact that they didn't
have to deal with nearly as much
headcount as they would have needed
without a solution we're running a
little bit short on time so just mention
one more which is another energy company
that we worked with again we're using a
different vendor it's the blue line or
the blue color there and the trajectory
of their completion was two two and a
half years for moving their completing
their migration with the five X
acceleration that we offered in our
solution after their chose us they
basically come you know compress the
time to six months for the same amount
of workloads and not only that but they
also realized about million dollars of
savings due to reduced headcount
that was required due to the simplicity
and automation of the solution so in
quick summary you know this is a time
for enterprises to make the move not
stay behind competition if you want to
move at scale I think Google cloud is
your choice and we strongly believe that
well Australia is a right solution for
time perspective you get a very quick
downtime or a very short downtime 5x
labor savings or 80% 5x X
generation compared to any other
solution out there and very easy
solution to work with thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]